[Aplausos]
se escucha si no bueno hoy día creo que
por eso speakers han hablado sobre el
miedo y yo ahorita me estoy muriendo de
miedo y la verdad es que
desde el colegio siempre sido de la
chica más tímida del mundo cada vez que
hacían oratoria that social poesía de
ese tipo de cosas yo era de las que se
escondían en el baño y no hacia la loca
hasta que la profesora se olvida de que
me tocaba a mí pero una de las cosas que
ha descubierto en estos años ha sido de
que las cosas más maravillosas esto es
mucho más allá del miedo así que con
todas las pelotas o los ovarios del
mundo voy a dar mi speech hoy día y voy
a tratar de no morir en el intento bueno
en mi nombre es y mira tengo 24 años soy
mamá de una niña de 6 años si hacen sus
cálculos se van a dar cuenta de que la
tuve a los 17 fue un poquito precoz la
verdad es que siempre fui precoz para
todos pueden preguntarle a mi mamá que
estoy en el público yo caminé a los 9
meses me quite el pañal a los 8 meses
tuve una hija tuve tener dni azul y
también comencé a morir mediante ese
tiempo
en septiembre de 2013 me hice un examen
de rutina y cuando vi los resultados los
números estaban más rojos que mi libreta
de secundaria y me asusté mucho así que
me acuerdo que fui con mi mamá mientras
mi mamá estaba lavando los platos y le
dije mamá creo que tengo cáncer porque
se me pasó por la cabeza y mi mamá
volteo y con ese carácter que la
caracteriza me dijo por qué tienes tu
pierna vamos a tener eso le dije a mi
papá llegó de viaje y le dije le dije
también lo mismo elige papá creo que
tengo cáncer
tengo una infección de la patada pero
algo tengo y me dijo ya vamos a ir a un
médico para ver qué nos dicen fuimos al
médico internista bien churro de pata
bien estábamos sentados ahí mi papá mi
mamá y hoy mi hija y yo estoy sonriendo
en el chico coqueteándole enseñando el
hemograma hasta que le entregué el papel
y la sonrisita coqueta del chico
desapareció completamente en vez de
pedirme mi whatsapp
me pidió un montón de exámenes de sangre
más y mis papás agarraron y me dijeron
sabes que este es el té de la consulta
un rato porque vamos hablar con el
médico espere como media hora afuera y
cuando mis papás salieran de la consulta
salieron en un nuevo automático
me acuerdo que ni siquiera voltearon a
mirarme o sea simplemente caminaron yo
no existía y se fueron y yo estaba
corriendo detrás de ellos recuerdo que
llegamos a la cochera y en la cochera
como que los paren seco y les dije
que fue ya estoy bien grande citado para
que me digan que tengo y cuando vi sus
caras
ya lo suponía y recuerdo qué
entre voces cortadas por el dolor y el
querer llorar
mi poco me dijo de qué
yo tenía cantar
y bueno creo que
y bueno lo que me dijo mi papá y me
prometió fue que íbamos a salir de eso
no me dijo no te preocupes porque vamos
a salir de esto y no ahí comenzó todo a
mí super travesía con el cáncer que ha
logrado cuatro años este nivel me
diagnosticaron comenzaron todos mis
análisis y me dice cosas locas que
aspiraron la médula y me tomaron una
biopsia hablando en cristiano lo que me
hicieron fue meterme una aguja de este
tamaño por la cadera y sacarme un pedazo
de hueso y líquido desde acá también
bien bonito no son un poco estrambótico
mi mamá casi se desmaya cuando no veo
nada pues luego vino lo peor que fue la
quimioterapia
yo tengo una leucemia que bien rara
normalmente cuando tú tienes a una
persona con cáncer te imaginas a alguien
a quien es en quimioterapia la vena y se
le cae el pelo y todo le va mal bueno en
mi quimioterapia no fue así mi
quimioterapia consistía en pastillas
pastillas que tenía que tomar todos los
santos días y esas pastillas tenían
efectos adversos así que todos los días
les tomaba y todos los días menos pasaba
vomitando en el baño
el baño era mi flaco todo el día estaba
abrazado al baño
en serio me salían manchas rojas por
todo el cuerpo me hinchaba de lugares
que ni siquiera sabía que se podían
hinchar
a veces amanecía con la boca de este
tamaño por esos días me pasó de todo
o se ha pasado de ser una persona a la
que no le daba la gripe a pasar a ser
una persona que se enferma de todo es
asqueroso es horrible
sobre todo cuando tienes 20 años y llegó
un momento en el que simplemente me
deprimí y dije ya no quiero más recuerdo
de que les dije a mis papás sabes que
voy a dejar el tratamiento déjenme
morirme en paz y ya no quiero más esto o
sea se acabó me acuerdo que me tiré a mi
cama no me bañaba no comía no me
cambiaba era un vegetal tirado en una
cama envuelta en un polar color rosado y
pasó una semana en que mi mamá me
aguanto así
después de la semana mi mamá tuvo las
pelotas que yo no tuve y me cogió de los
pelos que todavía tenía me llevo a la
ducha con agua helada y me dijo basta ya
suficiente y mira y me acuerdo de que
mentar me caía el agua helada en la
ducha
tuve una catársis impresionante y me di
cuenta de que por más de rim che que
hiciera por más que patalear por más que
yo no sé pues hiciera el cárnico me
parara de cabeza el cáncer no se iba a
ir y la única que estaba perdiendo el
tiempo en ello
y quiero hacer un especial este es el
punto en esto porque mientras estuve
deprimida me privé de llorar no quería
llorar porque siente que se llora hoy va
a ser peor y es mentira y ahora está
bien llorar es humano yo creo que cuando
pasas por cosas como el cáncer o perder
a alguien o perder un trabajo o una
oportunidad o cuando algo no te sale
bien llorar es humano tenemos que votar
las cosas malas para que las cosas
buenas vuelvan entrar a nuestras vidas
yo creo que el dolor limpia y nos deja
atraer cosas buenas otra vez así que si
les pasa algo
lloré grité maldigan insulten hacen lo
que quieran golpe de nadie
no no el penal en gol penal o no hay le
dijo eso golpe en algo pero está bien no
está bien frustrarse es lo más normal
del mundo luego de eso en altos y bajos
durante estos cuatro años que estaba
enferma
el año pasado mi cuerpo dejó de
reaccionar a los tratamientos y mi
médico me dio dos opciones me dijo o
dejas el tratamiento y te mueres en dos
años
o te trasplante la médula y
probablemente vivas una vida feliz y
tranquila no me dio muchas opciones así
que le dije bueno pues le trasplantó a
mí que voy a hacer que puedas ver me
acuerdo de que fui con mi papá allá con
su hija y nos sentamos los dos y me dijo
todo lo que me podía pasar si me
trasplantaban me dijo te puedes morir te
puedes quedar inválida te puedes quedar
ciega te puedes quedar sin pulmones pues
no caminar hasta horrible eres bien
bien tétrico para explicarlo esas cosas
sin embargo firme el consentimiento y
dije que si una de las cosas que le
pregunté en mi médico cuando hablamos
del trasplante fue si iba a perder mi
cabello
durante todo ese tiempo que llevé
quimioterapia mi cabello nunca se cayó
porque el equipo terapia oral no hace
que se te vaya cabello y ahí mi doctor
sabiendo lo vanidosa y perica que soy
con todo el dolor del mundo me dijo si
se te va a quedar todo el cabello de
todos lados
y le dije bueno al menos no me voy de
pilar
y por más que trate de tomar con humor o
sea de hecho es un golpe bajo porque la
sociedad de alguna manera es como qué
mujer cabello largo mujer bonita cabello
largo mujer sexy cabello largo y cuando
dios se me enteré que me iba a quedar
sin cabello fue como que rayos y ahora
que voy a hacer eso voy a dejar de ser
bonita y otra vez me vi entre dos
opciones o esperaba que mi cabello se
cayera solo por la quimioterapia o
agarrado en mi ropa vayas a hablar y
como soy un loco calato llévame a la
peluquería y me rapé la cabeza yo sola y
donde todo mi cabello
y cuando ya me vi pelada de hecho fue
chocante y yo tenía el cabello hasta acá
y verte pelada de frente de hecho es
horrible
me acuerdo de que me puse a buscar como
que hay alguna clase de referente de
mujer pelada se exige empoderadas
y no encontré ninguno
[Aplausos]
bueno ninguna ninguna ninguno y eso no
me pareció justo así que me acuerdo de
que me puse a llorar como que tres días
viendo me la cara diciendo mi pelo mi
pelo mi pelo y al final me paré al
espejo me mire
y me dije indira tú estás más buena que
el pan con pollo
no necesitas pelo te pueden salir tres
cabezas si quieres pero vas a seguir
siendo bonita y ahí me di cuenta de que
todos somos lo que transmitimos si
nosotros nos sentimos bien con nosotros
mismos la gente nos va a ver de esa
manera si tú te la crees la gente te va
a creer porque esa cosa eso está de
nuestra magia somos lo que transmitimos
a la gente somos esa energía y así
puedes seguir adelante y luego vino mi
horrible trasplante el trasplante de
médula aunque la mayoría cree que te
parten algo en el cuello mentiras en
realidad es como una transfusión de
sangre el problema es que ese
transfusión de sangre dura
aproximadamente dos meses que tienes que
estar encerrado en una sala de
aislamiento
en esta sala de aislamiento creo que
aprendí re aprendí y me volví a conocer
una vez más porque fue una experiencia
muy fuerte me hicieron 38 quimioterapias
en 7 días fue brutal
se cayeron en cejas mis pestañas mi
cabello
todo espero que tienen el cuerpo parece
un topo recién nacido sentí como mis
órganos comenzaron a colapsar y el
último día que tuve de quimioterapia que
fue el sexto día me desmayé dos veces la
primera vez que me desmayé me ve y
cuando trate de ir sola al baño pero
tuve la fuerza para regresar a mi cama y
caer ahí
y no cerró los ojos y no me dejé llevar
porque sentía de que se cerraba los ojos
yo no iba a volver a despertarme la
segunda vez que me desmayé fue ese mismo
día cuando mi mamá fue a verme fue arme
la clínica
y parece entonces y yo no podía hacer
nada sola no tenía ni siquiera las
fuerzas como para levantar la cuchara y
alimentarme mi mamá me tiene que ayudar
en todo así que mi mamá me llevó al baño
me sentó en el baño y lo único que
recuerdo es que todo se puso en negro y
escuché a mi mamá gritando
y ahí sí me dejé ir ya no quise luchar
estaba cansado
y de la nueva comenzó a tener flashes
flashes de mi vida me vi a mi chiquita
me vi adolescente vi a mis hermanos de
mis papás a mí sé
donde eso que te dicen de que cuando te
mueres toda tu vida pasa delante de tus
ojos no es mi tía de verdad pasa de
verdad pasa y es nada posible no y lo
último lo último que pude ver en eso en
ese momento en el que de verdad sentí
que me estaba muriendo fue que escuché
el llanto de mi hija atrás de mi cabeza
ese llanto de cuando era chiquita y yo
tenía que ir a la universidad y ella se
prendía de mi pierna porque no quería
que yo me vaya y fue su llanto en el que
de alguna manera me despertó y me trajo
de nuevo a la realidad y una vez que
volví a tomar conciencia y ya estaba
despierta después de haber visto mi vida
pasar delante de mis ojos me di cuenta
de que yo tenía una vida jodidamente
maravillosa yo lo tenía todo siempre lo
había tenido todo estando sana y estando
enferma siempre lo había tenido todo
tenía mi familia tenía mi hija tenía
muerte tenía todo y toda la vida me lo
había pasado quejándome y es estúpido
que tengamos que llegar al punto de
tener que estar muriendo no para darnos
cuenta de qué
de verdad es maravillosa y tenemos todo
lo que necesitamos así que también les
quiero decir a todos ustedes que viven
su vida plenamente y son súper
agradecidos con todo lo que tienen y nos
obsesionan pensando en las cosas que
creen que necesitan porque ya de por sí
lo tienen todo
luego de ese trasplante que ellos puedo
decir que me enseñó el cáncer
la verdad es que yo pensé que el cáncer
me había quitado muchas cosas me quitó
mi cabello mi cuerpazo me quitó a mí el
fugitivo que se desapareció el mismo día
de mi trasplante después de jugar mejor
eterno
en serio puede mandar la moto si quieren
pero la verdad es que también me ha
enseñado muchas cosas el cáncer me
enseñó que soy una persona bastante
resiliente
yo sé que me puedo caer sé que me puedo
hacer pedazos sé que me puedo tropezar y
me poder aplicar y meter la pata y todo
lo que puedo hacer
así escombros pero sé que puedo auto
reconstruirme
y sé que de esos escombros que me he
hecho varias veces porque la verdad es
que miedo de caer en la vida un montón
de veces de esos escombros en un sol y
se han solidificado mis bases como mujer
como persona y como ser humano el cáncer
también me ha enseñado de amor propio
porque como ya les dije somos lo que
transmitimos y si tú te crees que eres
la más linda la más churra el más guapo
el más sensual la gente te va a creer de
verdad creo y nada como le digo a todo
el mundo no dejen que sus problemas
cambien su esencia
yo puedo tener cáncer también tú tienes
un problema con tu jefe con tu esposa
con tu esposo con tus hijos con tus
hermanos pero no dejes que se influye en
tu vida y te la malogren no es una mala
vida es un mal día y créanme cuando les
digo que las cosas malas no vienen para
quedarse las cosas malas vienen para
enseñarte algo y una vez que aprendes se
van
y como le digo también a todo el mundo
si yo tengo cáncer por el cáncer no me
tiene a mí y nunca me va a tener gracias